[Music]  go the [ __ ] away  homelander what made you decide to join  up with vaughn a chance to use my gifts  to help make the world a better place  come on in not like this can look bad to  anyone i'm not a pedo by the way i don't  even have fingers i'm not a goddamn pedo  benjamin  [Applause]  [Music]  oh you guys really suck huh  [Music]  the idea is that the outer you will  finally match the inner you  picture the face you want to have  the life you want to have  just rub that all over your face  here we go  fire  [Music]  [ __ ] it  i understand your anger the violence is  never the answer [ __ ] you  shut up  [Music]  you have any idea what a thunderclap to  the balls feels like don't be such a  [ __ ]  holy [ __ ]  kill me  [Music]  james frenchy what'd you put in that  stuff  you